this is not what a distillery is
supposed to look like there are no
stainless steel pipes or racks of
barrels here this is more like Willy
Wonka's factory or a twisted Disneyland
and that's quite deliberate moving
through it involves a trip through a
tropical jungle and on a wooden raft
that floats on the plants cooling water
tank so when we designed the new spirits
we designed them with the idea in mind
of engineering a sort of place in our
imagination where we would want this
thing to come from and so when we built
the distillery we really wanted to
create environments for each of the
different spirits where you can go to
that imaginary place in our mind and
then sit down and have a drink in the
place we envisioned it coming from most
spirits distillery is the latest trend
in boutique booze making this place is
geared up as an experience but they also
create oak aged rum and peated whisky
but in an entirely new way
after a float down the river Red
Lanterns come up to reveal a whole new
space hidden these are fermentation
tanks but ready they're also works of
art so the five of us built everything
you're looking at from scratch we
hammered the stools out of sheet copper
we hammered all the fermenter tanks out
of sheet copper and soldered everything
together we sculpted the dragon heads
out of the jungle and in to the light
this is where some of the science
happens this is the reactor room so the
freshly distilled alcohol comes in here
it's inside this glass tube and then
floated inside that a little pieces of
wood that actually offcuts from making
barrels you can just about see one of
them they're floating inside and then
the whole thing is blasted with this
really bright really high-energy light
and that helps break down the wood in a
really accelerated way so it's sort of
the booze having to sit inside a barrel
for two decades bits a barrel sit inside
the booze
and they release some of those flavors
compounds in just two days people have
been trying to speed up that aging
process for a hundred years
these guys were awarded a patent for
this successful process because the team
here are inventors when it comes to
alcohol they're constantly trying to
find novel ways to make new spirits
taste like ancient ones infusing peak
flavors or artificially accelerating the
aging process so in the lab we're
working on all kinds of new different
interesting products that may have never
been done before and once visitors see
all of their sits back on the boat and
down to the island of dr. Moreau for a
taste of the petered scotches and then
through the jungle again running from
headhunters and finally enchanted gift
shop enchanted gift shop club on it come
on it complete with talking birds where
hopefully you've been persuaded by your
experience and the copious tastings to
take some lost spirits home with you
good eye whiskey